[Music]
could you tell me why you came out here
today clad in tape I'm here to support
the cause for women's rights at being
top free it's either everybody or no one
I really want to have the same rights
that men do to just go out and public
without my shirt on and I don't think
that it needs to be a sexual thing I
just want to feel the Sun on my skin I
was one of that I came out here to
celebrate women's equality and to hope
to expand it a little further
we fight for be able to be bare-chested
but if that can't be the case then men
should have to cover their breasts and
that's why I wear my breast cover to
this moment
so tell me did you just kind of stop by
just figure out what everyone was
standing around about yeah pretty much
obviously earlier and notice that they
were you know getting ready and I'm you
know County see is it a good idea we all
are equal it seems small to a lot of
people why bother right yeah I do think
it's a feminist issue I think though
that if we dismiss small issues that's
kind of a slippery slope you know it's
not up to men or really anyone to decide
what issues are worth fighting for if
it's meaningful to us if it really is so
small then you know why make a fuss over
it why not just give those rights to us
and move on to bigger things women being
told that they can't breastfeed or in
public or just seeing men wander around
or jogging without their shirts on and
women can't do the same they even get
arrested for it or good jail it just
doesn't seem right
so do you think I'll accomplish anything
with this event lots of googling that
will be accomplished but hopefully you
know I hope so I hope people you know
pay attention to more than just naked
people I mean you know as young
generations grew up and are less weird
than their parents I think there's no
reason that Americans can't get over
that point of this cause is feel free to
open your mind enjoy yourself don't
think about what other people think if
it doesn't happen today I am positive
that it's
happen someday in the future I mean just
look at you know when the first bikini
came out look when women were sent to
jail for exposing their legs yeah
[Music]